before I know what this is what well I
might be in overalls because I just got
done getting that sandwich but we also
got something else in the studio this
morning I don't know if everyone knows
about this dude this is the box you're
holding earlier yes huh you know what
did it no idea I know
play button is a very rare occurrence
that really symbolizes your channel
becoming a legitimate entity that people
follow a million subscribers is a lot of
people
this is YouTube what do we get official
YouTube with innocence oh I know this is
this poor I know it this is I know this
is moving down we've been waiting for
this you should take it from here then
do you know what this this car I don't I
never received anything from YouTube is
that the millionth subscriber
[Music]
[Applause]
I thought this Musashi's traveling case
I need that I totally thought this was
something else that I order to be a play
but I thought it was the play button
dude we got a play I like I like put
into the grad was like Graham we need
her play button for Corps Recruit he's
like yeah you just go on your account
settings and like grab yeah if I did
that and I thought this was it and I was
all excited to show it to you guys I
didn't open it this morning cuz I
thought it was the play button plug it
long as we got like a jelly
dude that's a pretty nice suit that's a
really nice suit case
I think Oh Susan filming cat hey Graham
in YouTube thank you so much appreciate
it where's the best he really is though
he's our players our overlord or
overwatch they're like it fights for us
a map of YouTube he's our cleric the
play button - yeah I mean I feel like
it's a good example that you shouldn't
get your hopes up too high in life did
one suitcase for like 9 dudes there's a
good day out actually
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah you guys I don't know anything
anymore given what happened last week
when I thought we received this but I
think I've got something very special
for you guys this is something much
different so we got a gold play button
floor corridor a while back it felt like
I was getting an award for something you
know something something we worked a lot
on we had done a good job at something
so it felt really really really good
it's been years and years and years in
the making to get the corridor crew /
santanico channel gold play button so
how Michael Nick you guys been working
hard and tirelessly on channel and I
can't wait for YouTube to honor you guys
the gold play button oh my god it was
joke I talked this up so much for you is
this another cease why are they sending
a suit
oh my god what corridor as well
they must have someone must look like
accidentally clicked order like pretty
good suitcases thank you at the same
speech before we open it each time like
we think we know what this there it just
so happens YouTube's sending out play
button sized suitcases for will handle
oh my gosh what my favorite part is that
it comes with a battery anymore I don't
know what's real anymore
well hey Nick yeah what are you doing
making food right now good guy you just
go to flexpro meals calm and use the
africo corridor crew 22 get 20% off 20%
off you're telling me that for every 10
meals I order two of them are free
going over Gord or crew 20 mom what are
you waiting for
I think we got another suitcase suitcase
it might be it might be a suitcase true
do it Carmichael Nick you guys to get in
on this
there's a smiley face on it this hi hi
we don't want to you know puncture the
suitcase all right here we go boys
another suitcase just phone
yeah Suzanne sent us a letter as well
from Vancouver there's a new type these
are the noodles that new new yeah you
know it was the standout right there on
the play almost a little cooler than the
last one now most lift it out anyway
thanks Alan is it made out of like pure
metals piers old actually that's not a
chemical that anymore and that's
beautiful
there'd be a lot of gold to be weighed
every look it's you it's you - oh it's
you - passing 1 million subscribers
corridor crew channel man how do you
guys feel I'm glad it's not suitcase
[Music]
it's smaller but there's more gold
exactly we got the other one like 1
million subscribers is a big deal oh
yeah how's it feel to be holding it in
their hands losing sleep does matter 10
is diamond and then in savings 5050 the
Ruby that shape as your logo like a
giant things and
ruby's with that we're about to find out
what hundred million is Nick came over
here to ask me to tell you that half the
people that watch the quarter crew
aren't subscribed to corridor crew it's
crazy it's a statistic that you can see
in our YouTube studio with that guys
we're not good enough to subscribe to
look how hard-working everybody is right
here right now it's so quiet sorry you
think it's all fun and games
turns out we just work super hard for
like nine hours of the day and then play
really hard for one hour of the day
anyways it would mean a lot to us if
you're not subscribed and you do so it
supports a channel it helps us do all we
do it helps our videos get to you maybe
you can help us get a diamond play
button